- - is improved - sexual predator levels
so a lot happened this week and part of
that of what is tied up in doing a day
in the life video so I'm gonna post all
the stuff to do with that on a separate
video which I will upload later in the
week I also realized that last week I
promised that I do a Q&A type video but
I realized that the lighting in my last
video really wasn't up scratch so I
invested by which I mean I moved it and
I've got a whole bunch of other
questions and I'll do a longer Q&A video
which I'll upload again later this week
so apart from all the standard stuff
that I've been doing that is the wing
bang meditation class and all the stuff
which happened on Thursday which I won't
talk about in this video because
otherwise it's going to be really really
long this week was a bit stressful
because I had to publishers do it on
Friday they might notice the pattern
that this is what happening third week I
have promised sheets chewing on Fridays
of odd-numbered weeks so there was this
there was to this week and there's gonna
be two in two weeks time so I didn't get
terribly much sleep this week because I
was working just all the time or the two
problem sheets in atmospheric physics we
were looking at cloud micro physics that
is to say why cloud droplets form and to
what size they will grow giving certain
temperature and pressure conditions and
what-have-you and some more macroscopic
properties of clouds then in theoretical
physics this week we were looking at
many particle quantum theory which
actually what I find a lot easier than
the previous stuff which means I'm
probably only going to get about 90% of
it wrong
if I'm lucky other than that the other
reason I didn't get much sleep was
because I stayed up for the u.s.
election now there's a large visiting
student population in Oxford of American
students and they're almost
overwhelmingly Democrat at least
innocent Peters so to be in the room
with like American snacks we had the
classic rare American curves we have
popcorn we had pizza all that kind of
stuff didn't see but to be amongst a
bunch of passionate Democrats and to see
Obama re-elected was really kind of
something even if it didn't involve
staying up to
stupid o'clock in the morning because of
the time difference and the Denny cell
was littered with people that just
couldn't quite make it and then sort of
bailed halfway free but couldn't be
bothered to move other than that I had
the last round at the University
Challenge trials which took place on
Friday I found out today that I've been
given a place on the team which is
obviously fantastic news but this means
that we're now gonna have to get ready
for the next round of University
Challenge so that is the level where
we're competing with other colleges and
in preparation for that I'm going to be
doing a lot of brushing up of my
geography my art history and just
generally trying to get smarter it's one
of these things where like you can
memorize these lists or you want but a
lot of times just random noises that you
can't prepare for two things which
happened which I can tell you about that
didn't go to were one the sigh of
Gangnam style fame came to the Oxford
Union and I didn't go at friend of mine
did and say oh I have proof that this
happened
and he's you know one of a long line of
people that come in this time I think
the highlight for me this time it's
probably gonna be Patrick Stewart coming
if nothing else I just want to ask him
if he can make something so if it's like
make my life also on Tuesday the college
did die Forks for walks it's bonfire
night and they had desserts which looked
like this they had desserts which were
bombs why on earth did I not go
but again friend of mine Curtis he has
his own YouTube channel which I'll put
in the description when I was kinda in
the picture some Peters has been playing
host this week to a series of lectures
by Mark Thompson who is the outgoing
director-general of the BBC and the
incumbent editor-in-chief of the New
York Times and he was giving five
lectures I think it was five of the
course of this week about the nature of
language in public policy and on the
Friday he was joined by the university's
Minister David Willetts now David
Willetts has made some rather divisive
to say that to put it kindly about
higher education in this country and
outside some Peters there was a huge
crowd of people who were protesting
about cuts to higher education increases
in fees all that kind of thing and it
was quite it wasn't it was nice it was a
peaceful protest rather than an
aggressive protest I didn't feel when I
had to go through the lodge and they had
you know policemen on duty and they were
checking everybody's credentials as they
came through I didn't ever feel at
threat or anything like that I didn't
actually go to any of the lectures this
week though I believe they're going to
be posted in full on the some Peters
colleges your channel if you're
interested though I don't know when
sometimes - I'm sorry again this isn't
terribly energetic I'm absolutely
knackered I have a full week of work and
then I actually went home this weekend
to see my parents and it was obviously
lovely to see them and everything but it
was one of these things where I slept
almost the entire time and that in
itself makes you more tired so I'm
hanging at the moment also I just came
back from the gym and I have an awful
lot to do tonight so I've got a film
this had it all this together do the
other two videos and get ready for the
physics society talk the next week which
is next week can be about the Large
Hadron Collider Chris Hayes is coming in
to do that
this week's talk is gonna be covered in
the Ben life video which this is
probably gonna be that shows of the
north because there's gonna be content
in those other two videos but if I put
it all together in one isn't gonna be
just one colossal episode aa blog stop
saying episode that's about it actually
for this week other than the stuff which
I can't talk about because they're gonna
be in other videos right thanks for
sticking around guys it's nice to see
that this has been useful to people you
know this is getting a great response
and I'm really grateful for all the
lovely comments that you've been leading
on these videos I really really do
appreciate it it's nice to know that it
is actually having a positive impact so
as ever if there's anything you'd like
me to cover in
ticular then please let me know and I'll
either cover it in a video or I'll do a
Q&A type video again but thanks very
much for sticking around and you'll see
me on this channel again in a couple of
days and another one of these vlogs on
Sunday next week